[موسيقى]
ابن رونالدو يرحل عن مانشستر يونايتد غرفه
ميسي تتحولوا لمتحف صغير وتواضع بون انصري
يلفت الانظار هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها
لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
على خطى ولده رحل كريستيانو جونيور عن
نادي مانشستر يونايتد بعد نحوي شهر من فسخ
النادي لعقد والده وبحسابي تقرير اعلاميه
فانه جوني جوني اكاديميه ريال مدريد التي
لعب لها من قبل وسجل 50 هدفا خلال 20
مباراه فقط وتتضارب الانباء حول وجهه
رونالدو المقبله لكن الاكيد ان عائلته
ستستقر في العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد التي
شهدت ابرز انجازات رونالدو الكرويه
وبعد انتهاء كاس العالم في قطر تحولت غرفه
ميسي في مقر اقامه المنتخب الارجنتيني الى
متحف صغير ميسي الذي قاد منتخب بلاده
للفوز بكاس العالم ستكون غرفته في قطر
متاحه للزياره خلال الفتره المقبله وكان
المنتخب الارجنتيني قد اختار الاقامه في
مرافق جامعه قطر عكس المنتخبات الاخرى
التي اختارت فنادق ومنتجعات فخمه خلال
مشاركتها في المونديال
هل تذكرون الدكتوره ايفا كارنيرو طبيبه
نادي تشيلسي سابقه الشهيره الى امكانيه
عودتها الى النادي بعد ربها على تغريده
لاحد مشجعي الفلوس على تويتر وكان المشجر
قد نشر صورتها بعد اصابه نجم الفريق جيمز
طالب منها العوده للفريق كان ايجابيا
وربما هي اشاره لعودتها الى الفريق مع
تغير الاداره السابقه التي اجبرتها على
الرحيل
نجمه منتخب المغرب ياسين بونو ويوسف نصيري
التقطتهما كاميرات المشجعين بعد وصوله من
اسبانيا متجهين الى ناديهم اشبيليه التي
توفي الامر ان اللاعبين التزم بدورهما
اثناء تمرير الحقائب مع المسافرين الاخرين
ولم يطلبه اي خدمه خاصه كما استقل رحله
علمتني طائره تابعه لراين اير وهي شركه
طيران المنخفض التكلفه حيث يبلغ سعر
الرحله بين الرباط واشبيليه الاسبانيه
علمتها نحو 20 يورو
[موسيقى]